This is a classic demonstration,
which involves what I would call a pickled Gherkin.
Many of you might just call a pickle.
The demonstration involves taking two electrically
conducting pieces of metal forks and sticking
them into each end of the goat kin,
and then applying a high voltage across it.
Now I must say immediately,
this is potentially an extremely dangerous experiment. And one,
you shouldn't try because if you touch the metal,
you will get a huge shock. Neil had a historic piece of operators,
which we used.
Unfortunately the plastic safety cover had been lost,
but because we were using it under controlled conditions, it was safe.
I found the piece of equipment about to be thrown out.
And I wrote a note to Neil saying, save it for periodic videos.
Probably we should go straight to watching what.
Yeah.
The first thing to realize is that when you pickle something,
you put it into a mixture of salt and vinegar.
So contains ions, sodium ions, chloride ions.
And so solution is electrically conducting,
but it's not very electrically conducting compared to metal.
So what you've got are two electrical conductors with a
resistance in between. And when you pass a current through it,
the resistor will hit heat up
To have here.
And you have to understand that Gherkin is a biological
specimen and biological specimens are different.
So it's not like doing a chemical experiment where the chemicals should be
exactly reproducible. As you can see,
this Gherkin is completely different from the other ones, not even as long.
So you can't expect everything to be totally reproducible.
What happens is that when you switch on the current to begin with you see
nothing and then, uh, one of the ends,
and it's important that it's at the end because the maximum resistance
appears to be where the fork goes into the Gherkin because
there's less opportunity for the electricity to be conducted that
heats up.
And it heats up enough for the sodium mines to give out light in the
same way that you may have seen from sodium street lens. Now,
what is interesting is because mains electricity in most
countries is so-called alternating current,
that it switches from positive to negative, positive to negative.
So the polarity switches round going through zero in
the UK, it's at 50 times a second in the States.
It's 60 times a second.
And if you watch the Gherkin under high speed,
you can see that the light flashes on and off
as the current changes. So if you think about the voltage,
this side is the so-called neutral, which stays at zero volts.
And this side goes up and down to plus
200 volts down, minus 200 volts up and down.
And the first time we saw it,
there was a strong glow from the neutral end.
And we spent quite a lot of time thinking,
why should it be the neutral land rather than why the voltage is changing?
So in the end we thought, we'd just try it again. And the next go,
can it went at the other end? So it's clearly chance
If you look at the pool goat in afterwards, it's a bit shriveled.
And the end where the light came out is child.
We've actually got hot enough to burn the Go-Team.
You may know of what temperature gherkins burn, but we didn't.
So we decided to use a thermal imaging camera.
The first thing that I noticed is you can see the steam coming out of the
Gherkin because the steam is hot and therefore is picked up by the camera.
Whereas our camera barely noticed it in the dark.
You can see that it really is heating up and you can see that the end where the
light is coming from gets much hotter than the other end.
We then thought that it would be interesting to try and increase the resistance
of the middle of the Gherkin.
So Neil cut out a piece from the middle of the Gherkin length.
This a hypothesis was that if we made the can narrow
at that point, that part of the Gherkin should get hotter because it's thinner.
It will conduct electricity less well. So it has higher resistance.
And the heating effect is related to both the current and the
resistance and the current going through the homework and must be the same,
but the current density will be higher in the small point and it will get
hotter.
And in fact, what we found when we looked with the thermal imaging camera,
indeed, it did get very hot there. Interestingly, even when,
when Neil had cut it,
it didn't get hot enough to give any emission from the sodium.
But you may remember we got quite excited why it went to one end rather than the
other. And quite by chance in this experiment,
what happened was that one end lit up. And then after a bit,
the other end lit up for a few moments,
both were blowing and then it went to the other end
And you can see really well with the thermal imaging camera that the
forks themselves,
the prongs of the forks get very hot because they're conducting
away the heat from this whole zone.
I have no idea why it changed from one end to the other.
Yeah.
I'm not an expert on Gherkin structure. And anyway,
it's probably pure chance,
but you'd have to do lots and lots more good things to be sure when
you look at these experiments and you can see there are videos of this on
YouTube,
you should always think what is the science behind it?
They're great demonstrations,
but so often they're wasted people just take it as a joke and don't
think about the physics or the chemistry behind it.
Okay.
Thanks for watching periodic videos.
If you'd like to follow us on Twitter or Facebook and all those kinds of things,
there are links in the video description. You can also support us on Patrion.
We really appreciate people that do that. It's a lot of fun.
You can even adopt an element if you like,
but of course the best thing you can do is do what you're doing right now.
And that's what your videos thanks for your support.